what we've done is we've we've taken
$7,500 from every American or 16 16,500
from every taxpayer $16,000 from every
taxpayer and then given some of those
taxpayers a check for $1,200 that that's
that's not helping we have taken two and
a half trillion dollars and only given
three hundred and fifty five billion to
small businesses where's the rest going
same place it went last time
[Music]
I'm Dave Rubin and this is the Rubin
report joining me today is the founder
of the blaze the host of the Glenn Beck
radio program and the author of the new
book arguing with socialists Glenn Beck
welcome back to the Rubin report thanks
man how are you I'm all right you know
we are in the midst of a zombie
apocalypse and I'm in the People's
Republic of California so I probably
have a shorter zone life than you do but
I'm okay yeah yeah yeah I'm good I'm
glad at New York glad I'm not in LA you
know move to the center of the country
for a reason and this would be it this
would be it so I guess the first obvious
question here beyond just the general
how you doing during Corona is as a guy
who's sort of been in mainstream media
and out of mainstream media and a
trailblazer in new media did you ever
think you'd be doing your show from home
like dave rubin does his show from home
all the time I tell you something Dave
it is because I've been in broadcast for
like 42 years now the technology and
what we can accomplish now we couldn't
have accomplished even ten years ago
it's phenomenal it's really phenomenal
how how the power of the media really is
in the hands of the average person if
they care to take it it's really crazy
so how reading you in the middle of the
country where you are at least a little
bit kind of safe yeah it's it's pretty
good it's pretty good it's not New York
thank God
[Music]
Texas is still free thank god we've got
a good governor who is not trying to
tell everybody exactly what to do you
know being home with the kids because I
my kids live next door so we're kind of
quarantined together so we got nine of
us you know living at home which is
this is nice it's nice it's times where
you're like oh yeah I gotta get I gotta
get out of here but most most of it is
good most of it is good so I know we
could get into the numbers about Corona
and all of that stuff but let's just put
that aside but let's talk about the
thing that I think mostly animates
almost everything that you and I do
which is which is freedom and liberty
so as we're hearing about lockdowns
being extended and just in the last
couple days we heard now in LA where I
am now we're at May 15th and we know
it'll go beyond that because it's not
like you just magically flip the switch
and suddenly we're all out there again
and we see this cascading across the
country how concerned are you that as we
just get more and more stuck in our
homes as we don't go out as we don't
socialize as we as you probably saw in
Michigan you can't buy seeds at stores
to plant your own game all of these
types of things I'm much more concerned
about that than I am the virus
specifically are you sort of in line
with that oh yeah so I said back in
January when we were starting to look at
this and I said this thing is gonna
sweep this looks like 1918 I said but
it's not what concerns me is not the
death rate what concerns me is what it
will do to the economy and what it can
do to freedom and I think that's I think
that's turning out to be accurate the
what what the Federal Reserve is done
what the government has done is
unprecedented and it's you know to
really fully understand it because the
the the system of the free market is so
complex and while it has taken a beating
for the last 20 years it is very fragile
and it's as if we were all on a 747 a
brand-new Boeing 747 and and the pilot
said you know what it's gonna get really
really bumpy up here so what we're gonna
do some of you had maybe one could get a
concussion or died but they're 400 of us
on this plane so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna
the engines off and right before we hit
the ground we're gonna turn him back on
I wouldn't be for that I would say maybe
maybe a couple people could bump their
head and maybe we could even lose a
couple of people on the plane I hate to
say that but nobody's ever turned the
engines off in hopes that you turn them
on at exactly the right time before it's
just a pile of rubble on the ground and
that's what they've done and I don't
know how effective it's going to be you
know they're talking about a via Cana me
where they just turn it off and then
pump money into it to preserve it and
then when you turn it back on it goes
straight back up it won't it won't go
straight back up it can't go straight
back up first of all you're losing you
know eighty percent of jobs that are
created or created by the small
businessman how many of them had enough
money just to pay the mortgage and their
rental on their machinery or their of
their restaurant they're not going to be
able to open up they're open they're
they're running on about a five percent
margin how many of those restaurants are
going to be able to a hold two months or
month and a half
then open back up when I don't know
about you Dave but I'm not gonna be
going running out to crowded restaurants
right away mm-hmm that's the last thing
that people are gonna do this is going
to affect us enormous Lee enormous Lee
and there's something else I yes go
ahead go ahead well no so with that in
mind so before we get to some of the
stuff that was done wrong what what
would be the right thing to do right now
so if we're concerned about all those
small businesses I mean I know you're
not necessarily a ubi guy you don't want
the government to just be handing cash
to people but what is the right thing to
do then in a situation like this so I'm
not a ubi guy and I've done a lot of
looking into ubi because I know what's
coming with technology and everything
else and I am I'm much more of a
futurist than a now estefy will and so I
have looked into ubi
it doesn't work however this is a
different situation on
talking about universal basic income but
this is a different situation the the
the crash of o8 was caused by many
things but the government and the banks
and then stupid people listening to the
government and the banks that's why that
was caused that in greed it just caused
that thing to meltdown that wasn't my
fault why was i bailing out the banks it
wasn't your fault Dave why were you
bailing out the banks this is different
no nothing anyone did except for China
was this the government turned it off
for the first time in history and said
you cannot go to work
well article 5 in the Constitution says
you better give me some money because
you've just destroyed me so you have to
make me as whole as you possibly can so
I m4 in this particular case the
government coming up with ways to feed
money into the system and help those at
the lowest rung of the ladder including
those small businessmen who are just
barely making it now you've destroyed
them instead what we've done is we've
we've taken seventy five hundred dollars
from every American or sixteen sixteen
thousand five hundred from every
taxpayer sixteen thousand dollars from
every taxpayer and then given some of
those taxpayers a check for twelve
hundred dollars that that's that's not
helping we have taken two and a half
trillion dollars and only given three
hundred and fifty five billion to small
businesses where's the rest going same
place it went last time
right so with that in mind is is this
just one of these things where our
system is so is so broken in so many
ways that every time we try to do
something to fix it we just create more
problems like we yeah we extend it so we
we survive 2008 but then we make too you
know banks are too big to fail what do
we do we make them bigger that we just
create bandaid on top of band-aid on top
of band-aid when my hope is that at
this thing is so profoundly different
that maybe it actually will get people
to look at the root causes and think
about it all differently do you think
there's any chance or am I just a
dreamer I think you're a dreamer on that
one because the damage has already been
done and the system has already changed
I think it's been baked into the
response you know the Fed had prepared
this this was a prepared response you
can read it in their own notes they knew
exactly what they were doing when they
came in to the president and he said
we've got a quarantine the country what
do we do the Fed handed him a book and
said here's what we think should be done
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlists
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell